welcome to the Toronto International
Film Festival what does it feel like to
be premiering your movie here I mean
it's an obviously a great honor it's one
of the the best festivals out there and
it's a great city great fans and anytime
you get to see a movie that you've
worked really hard on in front of an
enthusiastic audience and especially in
a festival setting it's always a really
that's a great time mm-hmm
is that nerve-racking at all because I
know have you seen any cuts of the movie
or is this your first time seeing it it
was asking the first time I saw it yeah
last night and yeah obviously we went in
did some ADR so I'd seen little bits and
bobs right but it was difficult to sort
of pieced together what the final thing
was actually gonna look like and so to
see it in that venue with a screen that
size and the sound was incredible and
with that number of people in the room
it was quiet yeah quite something talk
about you know the decision for all of
you and why you decided to take this
part I mean you all get scripts and
there are different reasons for
different movies for each of you but
what was it about this movie that you
said you know what I really want to be
involved I mean for me it was the it was
the combination of doing an action film
in this setting with David McKenzie with
whom I've worked before we had a big
budget to do everything creatively we
wanted to do in the just as you would in
any kind of I don't know a big
blockbuster film but then you have David
whose milieu is really art house cinema
so I thought my god if you can combine
those forces I wonder what baby that
would create mmm it does it really has a
different sensibility I think when
people watch it they may be kind of
struck by feeling like they've never
seen anything quite like it it has all
the the markings of an action film of
romance of a thriller and a drama and
all that but it has a different rhythm a
different sensibility that I think sets
it apart mm-hmm and certainly very
physical there a lot of training that
you guys had to do to be in this movie
yeah absolutely I mean we spent a couple
months fight training and and horse
riding and things like that you know yes
it was the best at the horse riding
and I think there was a matter of who
had to be better I think we all had to
look like we're professionals I've been
doing it for years yeah you know they
trained us pretty well and in order to
ride one-handed and swing a sword above
your head and and then and do it with
chain mail on it was it sounds cool it
sounds super physical the challenges
were higher I think that how making the
whole movie was there were all those
sort of challenges and no matter how
many months of sequences fight sequences
we would learn then there was the matter
of the the raw elements which was
Scotland and and and the brutal
brutality and the the unpredictable
weather and being in the lock of
freezing cold temperatures and then
still having to do the fight sequence
with heavy chain mail on so if those
those but that's kind of what gave this
a lot of scope and a lot of fun for us
as actors we got to play in in that in
that realm I think that's what McKenzie
does really well creates that sort of
atmosphere and then lucky for us we we
don't have to feel like we're
necessarily acting we can put all those
tools away and just be know yeah and the
accent
good job was that it was that hard for
you or was that yes really hard for them
did you just stay in that accent the
entire time shooting yeah I mean I'm not
one for do you know I didn't make people
call me mr. Bruce or any you should have
though right but it just by by having to
do it for you know 12 or 13 hours a day
you kind of tend to then go home and
start talking like that but it was
helpful because it's a it's a tricky
accent yeah and the reviews look good
today things are coming out there's a
lot about your scene and a lot about
things it has it feel it feels good
right yes I don't know I haven't I
haven't read them but I mean I was very
proud of the movie when we I saw it last
night and especially to the physicality
of it I mean it was like going it was
like going to some version of war you
know for actors or whatever obviously he
didn't sacrifice life and limb but um
there was a real sense of relief I
remember finishing the foam and seeing
it with my buddies who we'd all gone
through the same experience
the feeling of true camaraderie that
we'd we'd battled this beast of a film
and and made something I think quite
unique